à l'est de l'ukraine la guerre continue
il ment ce brasier au coeur de ce
magasin ses habitants presse le pas à
travers les fumées ils craignent une
nouvelle attaque
les frappes sont monnaie courante en ce
moment la maison a été touchée celle de
mon voisin aussi bien sûr j'ai peur
nous savons maintenant ce que sont des
lance-roquettes
sur la ligne de front la ville de sévir
audonienne ce qui est encore contrôlée
par les autorités ukrainiennes mais pour
combien de temps situé à l'est du pays
aujourd'hui cibles prioritaires de
l'armée russe
la ville est sous les bombes ces
policiers ukrainiens recherche dans les
écoles les bâtiments des habitants à
évacuer au plus vite
aucun cessez le feu les tirs reprennent
il faut courir se mettre à couvert
attendre une accalmie pour continuer les
évacuations
devant leur immeuble ses habitants
prennent quelques affaires dans ces sacs
plastiques
les policiers doivent porter cette femme
trop âgé pour fuir seul
je n'aurais jamais pensé devoir partir
d'ici
wen j'ai connu la guerre quand j'étais
enfant table à trois ans
aujourd'hui je veux juste mourir ici en
fait
dans le convoi beaucoup d'enfants
partance pour l'ouest du pays
et eu le temps d'aller à nantes non je
préfère rester ici avec mon chien
beaucoup d'habitants ont fait ce choix
reste et faire des provisions pour
survivre dans ses caves au cours des
prochains jours rester ou partir dans
l'est de l'ukraine aussi la guerre
séparent désormais des familles